lever palestina och kossa sionis men
lever palestina och kossa
sionis le le le
palestina
[موسيقى]
le
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه في السويد كان
كل شيء مناصرا لاسرائيل ويبدو ان الاعلام
نسي كل شيء يتعلق بالفلسطينيين والماساه
التي حلت بهم لكن جورج واخيه جاء الى
جوتنبرج وتعلمت الكثير منهم حول
[موسيقى]
ذلك فكره الكوفيه هي فكره لغه تفاهم بينا
وبين الشعب السويدي يعني جماعتنا لما
كانوا يلقوا الكلمه ما يجي خمسه ست اشخاص
لكن لما كنت امسك العود واغني يجي 100 200
ويزق فوا لي ومبسوطين طب انا لقيت انه
بقدر افهم الناس قضيتي والناس مبسوطه
وفرحانه من الصغير للكبير الكل بيجي
يسمعنا الدنيا
ماسوا
وبلشنا بال 1972 يعني من مده طويله ونكتب
قصص ونحكي للناس قصتنا يعني اغاني مش
مكتوبه لنا للعرب يعني مكتوبه انه للسويد
فهمهم شو حصل معنا كشعب فلسطيني وقد حققت
كثير من اعمال المبدعين الفلسطينيين
انتشارا عالميا يقول الناقد الادبي حميد
دباشي ان القضيه الفلسطينيه لم تعد قضيه
الفلسطينيين لوحدهم وتمكن الفن من ايصالها
الى العالم كله وبات الجميع معنيا
بانتصارها في نهايه
المطاف لم يكن النشاط الفلسطيني الفني
خارج فلسطين بمعزل عن
المضايقات اذ كانت تهمه معاداه الساميه
حاضره دائما لتقييد كافه الانشطه الثقافيه
الفلسطينيه حول
العالم
تعرضت فرقه كوفيه ومؤسسها جورج توتري في
السويد للمنع والايقاف في عام
2019 بتهمه معاداه الساميه بعد ترديد
اغنيتهم تعيش فلسطين الحكومه السوديه
مهمتنا ان احنا من عاد الساميه لانه
بخافوا من الاعلام وهذا اللي بقتل اسرائيل
هن عايشين على الاعلام
نتحد
نتحدى بصوت
الراس
[موسيقى]
تحيه لكل المقاومين بالكلمه باللحن
بالريشه بالقلم هؤلاء الفنانون الذين
ينافحون عن قضيتهم قضيه فلسطين ويقاومون
عنها
بفنهم